j'ai toujours su que j'avais des chances
de devenir
quelqu'un je vais devenir l'homme le
plus
célèbre du
monde monsieur le Président la
Confédération n'est plus l'Union a été
sauvé c'est
terminé
[Applaudissements]
liberté pour le
[Musique]
sud que sil passé on a tiré sur le
président lesémoins disent que c'était
John le
comédien est-ce que tu sais qui je suis
je suis un
symbole comment un comédien célèbre
peutil commettre un meurtre en public
devant 1500 personnes et réussir à
s'enfuir
de
mon je vous confie la mission de
capturer
John compl visorter attein à notre
gouvernement je
vousêess allez nous aider
pase sur la tête de
jete estver par des agents secrs
confédér
maintenant que Lincoln a tiré sa
révérence cette nation appartient aux
hommes
blancs je ne me rendrai jamais Dieu m'en
est
témoin que Dieu bénisse
l'Amérique